what assumptions do you make when you
meet a Jewish person are they based more
on media your parents are just
unreliable sources this is how I win as
you play along this episode of odd man
out
think of how you pick them we brought
together seven Jewish people I'm Jewish
I'm Jewish I'm Jewish I'm Jewish I'm
Jewish I am Jewish one of them is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize who is the odd men oh okay where
have all your families been expelled
from can we just like get into that like
real quick every Jew has a story about
being forcibly taken from their home my
family got expelled from Russia early
1900s moved to New York
are you Ashkenazi yeah okay versus
actually converted my mom is from the
Philippines my dad is from Mississippi
why did you convert my mom put me into
it when I was really young when I was
like six or seven so I just always grew
up with it so I didn't really feel like
I converted my family is polish I am
half Jewish so my mom through birth I am
Jewish my dad is Christian my SAFTA was
expelled from Turkey and my Sabo was
from Bulgaria good words yeah
does anyone else know Hebrew yes grandpa
yeah well you know fluently yeah do you
guys um like no all the holidays
everyone was throwing out questions and
answers and it's just tough to get your
earpiece in but I was definitely worried
that I'll just be voted off just because
I may not look Jewish
what's like the highest Holi holiday
anyone got a Jewish school I went to
Jewish preschool elementary school and
high school and learned Hebrew in all of
them so I'm very Jewish can you start
reciting like the first prayer of
Hanukkah
like the first word buckets I didn't I I
mean I know it's off first word it just
flows better this first one he said his
prayer really fast and it didn't sound
like a hundred percent to me
what's the prayer just like the two
words for like washing your hands before
you eat no no no not today yes quick
question cuz this will eliminate real
Jews real quick does anyone know what
Jewish penicillin is matzo balls right
there it was a little unclear where he
was from and why he was telling us like
certain things anyone keep kosher I
don't know he drove here for this I like
took a plane you flew here yeah I all
right we just want an excuse to come to
LA I was very comfortable for girls for
summers and the guys gave me a bit of
pause people always kind of had weird
books because I was I'm only half Jewish
so growing up you know it was in a very
like Christian environment I mean that
was the main thing is when we were you
know getting pulled out for the High
Holidays everybody just kind of was like
why do you get to leave like stuff like
that that's the only time it really came
up for me
I have a very Jewish name I have a very
Jewish face not something that I
expected to be voted out the first time
I definitely was expecting be able to
keep playing the rest of the game
I don't was my first pick but I wanted
to go here just to just be sure okay
so tell me why it's harder because you
know I am just Jewish through my mom and
there wasn't a big Jewish community
where I'm like mom Nikki is like full no
yes yeah of course so I didn't grow up
with a lot of Jewish community around me
so I didn't do a lot of like the stuff
if people grow up in LA or New York or
something like that they might have had
access to where are you from again
Massachusetts yes I didn't really have a
religious upbringing at all and then I
did go to college at Wesleyan and that
is in Connecticut and it does have a
larger Jewish population so that's
really where I did get to me a lot of
Jewish people and really start to
experience Jewish culture who said they
didn't do birthday it was did everybody
I did it in college that was like my
once I went to college it was a much
bigger Jewish community so like I got to
do stuff like that and I go to birth
right I was most suspicious of Garrett
because just some of his answers they
seemed like very quick and not very
detailed have we all been Israel yeah so
what's our favorite part Israel I really
loved um I think the Dead Sea was
awesome I think Israel is just gorgeous
and I was really afraid to go in the
Mediterranean Sea because I did not want
to get stung by jellyfish so I was like
okay sand I'm a beach guy so I love the
Tel Aviv and disc golf Beach Masada
going up and like looking down over the
Dead Sea everything what's everyone's
favorite dish that their mom makes my
grandma's latkes honestly the best thing
ever for his locker
you tell me some more about your
conversion I was just I grew up like as
a kid like d'Or in Hebrew school having
Jewish friends do a Shabbat every week
during the holiday so it wasn't like oh
my gosh I'm Jewish now I was just like
okay that's totally fine to convert but
just in the name of the game I was like
okay if you converted maybe you're not
actually Jewish maybe someone you know
converted do you feel really in touch
with Jewish culture so how about Oscar
knows friends who don't buy German cars
for that very reason like yeah the
Holocaust is probably one of the worst
events in history so I don't date for
for anyone to not connect with that that
would be a problem but for me I would
say a lot of Jewish history I don't
connect with just because it's not part
of - three it doesn't get don't connect
to it does that make sense yeah did you
face any discrimination being Filipino
and Jewish all the time
absolutely what about people like
finding us like kind of discriminating
in like semi positive way but not really
at all when like when they say and the
guy was like oh you're Jewish you're
powerful you got power you've got
connections and I was like I
[Music]
he said his mom was Jewish and if you're
born from your mother and she's Jewish
that makes you a full Jew so he just
kind of seemed like the one to me from
the get-go I kind of saw it was coming I
knew it was gonna be a little bit harder
people who are Jewish are very you know
practicing in their culture and to you
know have all the little details down
and things like that is definitely hard
for somebody who didn't you know grow up
practicing Judaism after Garrett got
voted out I was kind of actually weary
about Arielle I want to hear more about
your because I mean there are Israelis
that that aren't Jewish and like that
yes that's cool too I was thinking about
this hold I was like oh my god but like
are you practicing or no so I I do I
went to Hebrew school I went to the JCC
at first grade I i switched a private
school i've academia can we speak right
now and i thought i was getting scared
people were gonna start voting for me
because i was definitely putting out
more israeli than jewish and that is
kind of my identity like i definitely
fall into that more because I am a
secular Jew I'm black Chinese and
Filipino and for most places I go well
people just don't even know what I am in
general Oh
add Jewish into mix and that really
throws people off you said you were born
here I think born and raised in LA yeah
but I went to school in a very
conservative state and now I'm back
because it was really hard and part of
the reason it was so hard was because I
am Jewish and I did not feel accepted
yes there were a lot of people who did
accept me but you know sometimes a
little bit of hate can overrule a lot of
love and you said you went from a Jewish
high school yeah Jewish elementary
school Jewish preschool Jewish high
school she was just so outgoing and
talking about her experience of going to
an out-of-state school and that wasn't
Jewish and since she'd went through a
jerk or her whole life I think that was
one of the big things that kind of went
off in my head that maybe it was her you
know how do you go from a Jewish school
your whole life and not go to Jewish
college I was on a dating app recently
there
a guy who sent me a photo of himself
bottoms on but he was shirtless because
he was like really buff and he like
wanted to show it off I didn't care he
had like a lot of tattoos and I was like
looking at it and he had a giant
swastika right here I messaged him back
I said am I being pranked like like and
I said why do you have a swastika on
your arm he said it's a Chinese peace
symbol and I said oh honey oh honey no
like no more my first day at Calabasas
high they were swastikas all over the
wall freshman year my sophomore year
this kid came up to me is that I hate
Jews like I am a full anti-semite I hate
you and your people and I'm like dude I
don't know you like we're just in a
class together why are you at this
school if you hate Jews go move
somewhere else so he doesn't even know
you
I've been told you know you and your
family you should have died in the
Holocaust you and your people are evil
you don't deserve a place here things
like that and it hurts but at the end of
the day I feel also like it make me
stronger that reminds me how do you guys
feel about tattoos oh I have a tattoo
and I have done a few yeah yeah I don't
have any I won't get me I just live with
somebody who's Jewish and have been in
the culture now for like yeah a year and
a half yes because he was sitting right
next to me it was really quiet so I can
tell when people were asking questions
that he wasn't stepping in to answer
them yeah so as the mole I came in
actually taking stories from people who
are Jewish and kind of co-opting them as
my own because I had you have a lot of
Jewish friends so I have experienced the
culture through them I'm just happy I
made it past the first round I was
surprised that they voted Adam out real
really quick it just shows that you
can't tell who somebody is just by
looking at them you really have to get
to know them a little little better
[Music]
I'm a Jewish atheist which if it came up
it might have been something that would
have gotten me in trouble more so but
it's your culture it's your everything
it's a big identity and we need to hold
on to it because if we don't people will
try to make us do it by force within the
Jewish community there's probably more
stereotypes than outside of the Jewish
community by that I mean there's a lot
of judgment within some of the
communities whether you're more Jewish
than someone or less Jewish than someone
you came from Israel you came from
Russia from Germany to the States I
don't make it the full thing but it's
very much part of me and my values and
the way I live my life and you know
they're not that many Jews in the world
and so to be part of such a small but
very close group is actually really
rewarding in a lot of ways and I'm very
happy with being Jewish and I love it
when did like everybody become a
Democrat honestly when I was at school I
grew up in a really small town in
Nebraska was very white we had Fox News
on TV I am a Democrat I'm a Democrat I
am a Democrat I'm a Democrat I am a
Democrat I'm a Democrat I'm a Democrat
one of them is a liar
[Music]